and we are going to discard the and right here
basically there are no formulas that
is calm and we are going to talk
about technologies yes but no
basically we are going to present the dilemma a bit
quickly we are going to try to understand
the underlying problem break it down a
little so that it is  understand the motivation
and then it will go on to explain a little
how we cold take actions
to attack this problem in
real cases the project we are
working on and then we are going to mention
some trends related to the subject and
the closing conclusions I understand
that the  lunch all the more thinking
about lunch there are no pictures of food
that either so that should help
a little so we start well the
topic itself even the title is
argued in fact it comes from having read
a lot of articles that mentioned
this problem
the dilemma  80-20 the 80-20 rule in note
science
but they all point to the same problem which
is basically that the least of the
time  or in a hotasa project in he is
dedicated to doing analytics he spends
much less time than the rest of the
tasks here I ask in general is it his job
some feel identified with
this work of leaving or rather
spending less time what we like
do at work with respect to the rest let's
see if they raise their hands I want to see if
there are 180 20 here also of course in 60 more
but basically the underlying problem is
this and we are going to start a little so
the first thing we ask ourselves is why it is
a dilemma because this  word good a
dilemma if we consult the definition it is
a difficult situation in which
any option we take is going to have
an unfavorable or bad result it
even
sounds a bit pessimistic so let's
put it in context with an example let's
suppose that with my team we
we agree
[Music]
we agree and say well
we are going to spend more time doing
experiments like learning
so we have to sacrifice something  ar we
sacrifice what is data cleaning
to validate check this data
the result of this usually
what happens is that we hit the
wall when we assume that the data
is all right and we want to start
doing the magic machine landing
finding  problems the values
either to bloggers inconsistencies and
even business rules that do not appear
as dirty values ​​but are very
difficult to identify
then really this decision in the
end ends up having an unfavorable result no
then this this problem in fact
occurs in any type of  projects are not
data science itself, this is
finally studied as the triple
restriction problem where we have this
triangle that is usually quite rigid,
especially in the context in which
we manage a climate where
we are data science providers, we have
to enter a business to understand it
and offer a solution and here this
triangle is rigid because the real
Costs are already stipulated, they are fixed, and
even if you wanted to increase your team,
for example, even if you wanted to have a
budget, it is quite difficult, in
reality, how difficult it is, this scientist considers
the time, they are all already
agreed, especially because they are
business times to meet and the stop  it is
even something to take care of the orders because of
the orders that they make you want to
aggravate more things and it is something that you have
to take care of so that what is
compromised in the end is quality and what
is quality basically how rich are
the analytics and what can you  When doing
analytics, I mean from creating an
idea, a prior analysis of data, to
adjusting a model in general.
So,
basically, the curious thing here is that,
also as comments,
clients generally assume that
once they give us the data, we
start.  to see analytics we began to
look for airline models and it is not
reality there is a lot of variation to do and
there is all  o a challenge of managing
expectations of them and educating them in
some way and thanks to these
expectations is that o high expectations
that there are industries continue to
invest in agencies something fancy and
when things go wrong
the projects fail this is a well-
studied case of  garner that back in 2016 he
predicted to 2017 he said he won 60 percent
of the magill life project and in
general to fail at that time alone
or pessimistic and actually quite
conservative it was 85 percent in
what was relieved of the results what
that failed
going to more current numbers recently
in May another harvey was published that has
dedicated those of txus in these types of
projects where they interviewed more or
less 30-40 companies that
were working on machine la net
these are some results almost  80
percent stagnated before reaching
production, that is, they are going to experience
no, they never showed value
almost all the companies 96% that is
n agree that the biggest challenges
are in the part of data quality control
and labeling to make
majin lane you wanted to make your
teams everyone starts by putting together their own
team with all the energy to apply
data 6 but at the end of 70  % end up being
outsourced, especially activities
more related to labeling than making one
more model on the net, which led to
production much faster,
so it is really important to
deal with this problem so that this
reality changes a little, so what can
be done about it, and that is  nothing is
just a dilemma and that's it let's do something we have
to answer absolutely we have to
take actions to change this
so when we want to optimize the
effort that is to say well I really want to
take more time more time
to do analytics
when we talk about optimization we talk about
clear scalable processes  to
precisely identify the areas of
optimization the fundamental process that  and
we have cold to make an
atta sense project is this one that we put together that is
quite based if you saw the one from ibm
crease well and maybe the one from microsoft
live from microsoft data ainge is
very much based on that and this is our map
to be able to start and  finishing a
project is going to guide us from the
understanding of the business when
we get to a project all the part
of data collection and preparation that
we have to do
modeling make a diploma because we are
going to production and validate that business
in production that really produces
value yes  This is our map and it also
helps us to identify where
the effort is distributed, both in
the stages that we identify with the
roles and which are the most key here,
so the quick view can see
that the most concentrated part is in
analytics, both in the  definition as the
implementation covers 25% of the project
and where we know that there is greater
friction is in the first and second
stages in  the end in
business understanding analysis and in
data collection those stages are the ones
that we respect the most because we know that
friction occurs so to
double-click it does not try to understand a bit
in terms of tasks we also
did a survey
and estimated a distribution of
efforts for these two
main roles that we have in the acens project,
both the datacenter and the
tintin, and then we barely identified
the tasks and basically this
distribution can be estimated
now if you use scrum they grab and add more
or less the story points that are
assigned  to each one of the tasks and they
try to put together this distribution more or
less we did that work and then we
identified which are the biggest tasks
if you want that you can see that they
are more focused on what is the
exploration data collection and
also on the  quality control in
the want of the data that we are
handling so here the issue is that you
know  We think that these tasks are big because of
the complexity and the complexity is
very much from the context to the context
of the business, even though we have very
good skills, it will always cause friction
because it depends a lot on how the
data is on someone on the client side and
how much work  what must be done to be able to convert
them to values ​​yes
then in fact to vary this distribution a bit
we use some reports such as the one from crowd
flower that was published in 2016 which is the
grec everyone speaks when they speak the
language 80-20 ok it shows this disproportion very well
yes  you want the one here the one
that published very recently that also
asked about what are the tasks that
demanded the most time in data you feel the
subject that was very concentrated jamay
online and they asked me about
business analysis that for us it is crucial to
understand the  new business is a matter of
receiving data and doing more in mind
so we prefer this that we have it
mapped to our process
ok then  So far, I take the opportunity to
drink water, more than anything, a rich man.
The important thing is that you really understand the
underlying problem that
the time you are dedicating is much less than what
you would really like to implement and
enrich an analytical approach, and the
second key is that it is important or
at least believe me to optimize it because if
not all this remains in the experimental and
the metrics that we were seeing will pass
where the garbage is thrown away it is not
taken to production and the garbage is finished
yes then that is why we are going to present
two cases to some cases  In reality, of
projects that we work on
where we concentrate on this type of
tasks that they mentioned are the
largest, yes, and here we are going to show
technologies in bookstores in the country, we are
going to give it a little bit of that touch and
then we go with the first case  which is
the product of champions we have
in this product that was made
basically identifies something that is to say the
probability that a beaver of  je of
using a service that is a problem
done we arrived we did the
data analysis we adjusted a model
but for this case I am going to concentrate on
what comes later where when
the model is already adjusted and validated and we
have to put it into production and  provide
predictions to the client if I have
concentrated on that part
the initial idea was that these
predictions be housed in their data
warehouse that was based on
iu's oracle database and they were going to
have an integration with a
castón dashboard called dartford in table
and then there they are going to be able to handle those
predictions if that original reality
the problems that arose in reality
is that the tab ornass issue, which in
general is a fairly general problem,
all companies are being governed
in terms
of the little documentation that there is  of the
data that is being handled, both of
the business rules that are in the background
and the data dictionaries, that is, seeing
a table and not knowing  what does
each of these columns mean
at the same time there was no data stewart
someone responsible for governing the
data I remember for example that to
simply consult some
inconsistencies about the columns to a
chain of 33 35 emails where there were at
least 8 people involved and keep
adding  more people
that was the chaos
and obviously how this impacts on the
big problems that we can have
data quality very difficult to control
data quality not only in modeling that
we end up doing but
later when you have to generate
projections take care that the model is
generating things that make sense an
output that makes sense and at the same
time also their environment
was not friendly obviously you are
restricted in technology but at the same
time in performance it takes 35 minutes
to query 50,000 rows so it
was quite restricted
so what actions do we take let's go  to
mention two of the several we were
po  On the one hand,
force the organization of the data on
our side, we are not going to change its
organization, but at least what we are
going to bring to the model and to
generate the output is organized so
that we can process it well, so
we have our own concept
of  high law so basically the
architecture is how we
moved the data and deposited it on
our side to be able to do things
right the origin is going to save a little bit
the diagram things were consulted in
databases in oracle queries in sql or
even files that were  they moved in a
falsetto through that ftp for example all
this movement with a module
we made the query and moved it
through kafka I don't know if with what is
basically a
data streaming technology where we have a
producer and a consumer that are  they
communicate by topics if it is
asynchronously that which has one of the
good advantages
then by layers keep moving so much
the raw data of the query such as the
events that arise during that streaming
and the orchestration of this movement
occurred with string sets here I take the opportunity
to ask if anyone used stream
sets or knows this life and they know
well very similar night fights in fact
I had been using  knife also villa
stein sets because above all with the
help that the wifi did not seem very
unfriendly to me and the hour that has very
good connectors strings sets of hita
collector so with this orchestration axis I manage
the data very well for our
side where a  Let's say a series of processes,
if you want, by formatting and
curing until it can be deposited at the
destination, which in this case was our
country and it is in that 3 for the
slow data to be able to deposit there to be
cured, analysis and then when it is already
production in a  database in
what age mode is where we
end up depositing the
predictions and showing if now
everything is cured processing  we
did it with developments in python and what about
if you want in the framework
of airflow workflows it is assured that you
know it I think there is a talk or there is a
talk about
that where basically your development in
paita in python if you go in this case they
were  pandas because there weren't that many they
weren't a large volume of data you
build it up in terms of payton operators
that connect in a
workflow in the flow and the good thing about that is
that it not only organizes your development
but also monitors it to see where  it
works that is great
we had been using louis and as we saw it
I think there is a trend that is going to happen
well then thanks to that we were able to
be more verbose if you want in how
the data moves not only to
analyze it once but we
have  that generate predictions
frequently so be able to control
the changes there so the second
action that comes up is how we
control the quality all the time
by request  So we have to generate
predictions every week, that is the
frequency that the business is handling,
so in each of those predictions
we not only, obviously, sorry, in
each of those executions, we
generate predictions, but we
tried to give corrective actions
regarding the quality of the data.  What
happened to us was that there was a lot of
divergence, for example, you can see
an example that 600 of 600 customers
had problems with age, both
null and void and outside the range of 120
years and three years and gender, which are
files that we  it seemed important in
fact it did not seem important to us they were left
in an important file they were high
in our model
that has changed a lot over time and
we have to show it to this
strategist user so that he can take action
and correct it and that the predictions are enriched
and then here  the solution
was not only for the flower to be by
our side to be able to control that,
but also to offer  take corrective actions
so that they run and
correct their data, we can
have a good outcome there
if that is more or less what the two
main options that we take that
product we pass to the second one that is
produced after three months of expectation
I have to drink water  So this
is usually cold when we start the
relationship with a client, it is established
as in the framework of a skin if where
you want to test a concept that is
basically to compare the current approach
that the cast omer has with the one that
we propose and compare it  in the
testing campaign to precisely
see it in production in a few increments
the best so then this comes within the
framework of a three-month piece and
then it ends up being agreed for
improvements and productivity in this case the
product was from netflix action
both  of the next best thing to
offer a product cross elin up
selling how to allocate a dry channels
tomer or even offer some
b  benefits in particular is so
basically looking at it as a recommendation system
and the framework of two or three months is not
something that we decide because if they are the
times that they manage in the campaign, as much
as we would like to make it longer,
the marketing campaigns last that long and there are
that trying to offer value in each
of them yes
and as we said during a
test campaign we go to production we
compare ourselves and see what the
increases are in terms of the cap is the
main one to precisely compare the
efficiency of the approach is the
conversion rate  I know how many
recommendations ended up registering
people who were made not ok
and a big problem that happened and that
always happens is that as they change
during the same development the
business rule
is already very tedious to compile and
get to a business  and compile all the
necessary documentation to understand the
approach how it is handled as it is handled in
the campaign one would expect you to have t  All
the documents to look for and that's it
and the truth is that it is making
explicit requests because they assume a lot of
things and have them distributed
everywhere so it is an arduous task
at the same time those documents change a
lot in the time between campaigns they
try different things then
compared between three past campaigns and
the ball changes a lot it is very difficult to
try to understand how to
compare the current approach and lastly
the restrictions that put you at the last
minute
days before the campaign something happens the
marketing campaign and it is a
restriction  If he doesn't accept, you don't go to
production, so you have to
adapt, that's
ok, so what did we do for this?
We're going to mention two
main actions on the one hand, and how we
can develop to have the best
possible least friction from
experimentation to going into production.
whatever we do experiments and
development after it has to go to
production  tion easy although these
rules obviously change in terms of
development the culture of ebay first
first develop the interfaces use
many data modes while
the data is not there because the data is always late
until just having everything set up to
experiment and then have our
data plan  and the second thing we did was
an internal tool
that we developed called
magazine that precisely tries to
speed up the development
of pablos between data so if you
want to look at it as an era of
data frames in terms of what was
developed in a way and then  choose
if you want it to run in sparc if we want to
return from large data or in pandas for
small volumes or it has been developed in
a way and then choose the baqué and that's it
now it sounds quite ideal here the one
that intervenes was crucial to be able to
develop this is apache arrow  development is
moving a lot to
make all technologies compatible in terms of
tell us how they are allocated in memory,
so the park took actions in this
regard
and that was the panda judges
that are producing that today
where the certified functions the
cast functions take as you can
do you can express them in terms of
pandas series and  With this, using the
pandas hoist vector is much more
efficient than the iev as if thanks to
that we make many pandas and spark compatible,
so we can develop in
a way and then choose the
back end and run from a grandfather in a
technology to which  another if that was key and
we developed this technology and it
allows us precisely to
develop a way to take advantage of the
development of other projects and then it
depends on the volume
we choose what the package is
some example so that it does not sound
so untrue
this more or less goes here  to show a
simple analysis of basically the
known data set of wine reviews,
how to obtain the top 5 of the
most expensive wines  red wines of the
red category that are have a score
of more than 85 points
so in bands more or less it looks like
this here the operations they are
doing is on the one hand the casting of
both the point and
price columns the filter on  score I want to
keep only those that are greater than
85 points then I had to calculate a
flag to say when in red wines I
can do that simplified it is not
basically if the description of the wine
has the word red
and then a group and I keep groups
by  price and I prefer those that have
more prices of those types of wines and
then this more or less 25 in panda and
in sparc that changes like this
then in the park the development to be
able to calculate this function of knowing if it
is red we have to do a  panda to
judge 10 have been born
and note that all the operations
are already developed in terms of a
data frame and not as we saw before that one of
them is
impacted only in one column if
in c  hen you see the third line israel
then this moment how it looks in sparc
or the code is a little longer but it
does the same thing and in the same result
and this is more or less how it looks in one of
the online gas apis
similar line  to pandas but here what happens
when we want to calculate these and know
if we don't make a beach for red and
note that the beach is determined
with the lambda in terms of a panda
although then when it is going to be executed
in pandas it will run as nothing  and when
it is going to be executed in sparc
and in the background it is going to run the
widget bands to be able to calculate this
this by foot is online common line the one
we prefer is
this basically having a real
problem not line lines or functions
going around but that  in a list of
transformations to be able to express all
our development this is crucial
because it is really here that
when something has to be changed it changes the
business rules we are discovering
things  in the columns, select
which filters are going to be applied, which ones are
not, which ones are the transformation and touching a
few things is key to just
experiment quickly and go to
production with less friction and this sped us up a
lot, notice that it does the
same thing and they are all operations  if
they want a partner that is
grouped in a list and then a fit
and transforms kahn, the fit is necessary
but it also happens when, for
example, in a standard scale, it needs to
join if then there is the api of the
plan that we used from gallo
we had  less
and the second action we take is
basically ok all the
data
processing we make it more flexible so that when
something happens there is not much friction
we should also do the same for
modeling so for that basically
in our recommenders other
recommender systems are made up of
two forms for  aside the modules of
own in situ for a given action
then basically the
cast over propensity that responds well to an
action
and they are imagine adjusted with em
sembla landing we prefer to do it
this way either with exit bus using
grand buste machines or using I know that
honoring forest we are just watching and
so now we basically have the
propensity to  take a cast for
different actions and the easy thing is to say,
well, what is going to be a recommendation in the
action that has the best tendency and
that's what it does in business
when we arrive in its
optimization scheme, but here the issue is
that we have to  comply with certain
business rules that impose on us, for example,
the minimum and maximum quotas for
recommendations to be made for each of
the shares
and quotas must be met
eligibility of shares must be met iron is cost
in that they are very thin that they were not
implemented for example of  the
premium products that you are going to recommend
and this population of affluents that there is
a 70:30 ratio I don't know why but
there must be about 70 30 between these
two products and if we have to do that
change by hand and very difficult then
we have to give a way in
the assignment scheme to contemplate this and
for that reason -their master optimisers here I
take advantage of what they already gave me  all the
background of gastric optimizers
based on integer linear programming
julián in this case they are
basically they put together the matrix to say
which action is going to go with each caste more not
only for the best action but for
multiple actions there are several runs
the top yes  we want better actions
and we implement
this in this case with sound that is
developed in julia there is in development
juliaca there are two new countries I love there is
one basically we chose this one the
equivalent continues it is country in fact they are
where there is no talk I think it said ex
spice  we have also implemented there
we began to present it there we had very
few it is only to test
amp comparisons that it has many and
q  they are the same it is just as easy to
implement
this allowed us, for example, to try
different free and expensive solvers it has
an anecdote we started with the free ones
that if the lpg here took more or less
for a million chaste mary 6
dwelling actions 42 hours in one
amazon machine we went to another one that calls yes yes
it is much more elaborated
we touched many parameters we arrived at
that they run 10 or 12 hours and then we went
to the payments we said that's it
let's go with grow three minutes in three
minutes it
happens that it was ten thousand dollars in
cent
then well we went to mou sec and a
little cheaper and it is in order in
10 minutes with that we stayed then we
developed in a way that is an
example of how and julia simply a
with trains quite simple to go through
the selection you made  and impose that
the stops out in those products there is a
minimum and maximum to respect and that's where
the optimizer runs, so in a few lines it's a
dessert
and well it's the same  We are implementing an
ad ex spice but the truth is that
camps in that is much more flexible
ok
so far more or less an overview
of how we were responding
even in the face of certain problems that
reality broadcast to close I don't know
how we are on time
I think there is hunger  at 5 wind and day you
then a few trends no more
so it seems it will continue to be a
cata governance challenge this is not going to change
in the short term especially for
example the 2 alex are
evolving because they want to centralize it
is great to centralize but
Obviously, more entropy, more integration
with different sources, is going to be achieved. If you do
n't organize genes from those sources, we're
going to have chaos. So, for
example, you can see that there are trends
in diet fabrics or nate, virtualization warnings,
that they all have the same centralization,
but then it remains  on the business side
how are they going to organize that information and
on the other hand there are also other
trends in c  With this that is fashionable
block change that really seems
to be very useful in how they are going to be
focused on the provence and the integrity of
the data as being able to
somehow track everything
that was said to him what was  produced on the
data until it reaches a database,
then in one more way
, database biotechnologies will
migrate to using elx to blogging,
for that, perhaps it will be a good
utility, at least to understand the
problems that  The data passed until we
reached the table that we are seeing and
another challenge is going to be the issue of
regulation as of March, sorry in May of
last year, city art is already in force
in the United States, which is
how they regulate the services they use
data and information and this must be
taken into account when making
solutions, especially with us who
make products abroad in how
we use the data of the
sensitivity that they have where we
deposit them  amos and what do we do with that so
this is also going to make a general
prediction for this topic
so this is the truth that the
tendencies are more to be pessimistic but
well they are all the challenges that
arise how are we going to attack this
problem and on the other hand perhaps  the
culture of data ops, that is, on the one hand, it
is
like we have different
social roles, specialization of the role so that
the data center concentrates on
analytics and the dt engineer on preparing
the data for that, but also the
culture that you have incorporate
concepts of  dobbs to be able to precisely
develop the way that later there is
rapid production so each one of
the aspects that is being addressed is to
obtain data it is reproducible today
we all have our jupiter
notebook action experiment of the people
strap on another computer locally and it does not run so
there is  technologies that precisely try to
attack that, for example to take care
that it is already 12 years old where it deals with the
data in  the platform with everything used
raises everything to experience we
have the peace of mind that if someone else
runs for whom you will be able to reproduce
everything and a unified platform for that
and now the same concept is being given
much more in kiwi flow and extended here
barnet is
that  it was developed a year ago more or
less it is taking quite a boom with
also with the same concept of
trying that your plan developments for ma
jin the mind is to have the
docker container context that are orchestrated
by trivalents if that is being
moving a lot but that side then
as we develop for that in
fact we as developers
should test everything as services
because it precisely exists when the
battery is finished and we are finished it is precisely
we should develop in
terms of services because now
everything moves as services so
adapting is and  also the challenges in
terms of automation precisely the data
culture  The ones that you can see in
manifest if you want have more effect,
even everything tries to automate
certain stages and that the rest of the
datacenter concentrates on a
few if then kit exo wayne anti that
I ran out of
battery ethics if we have little time and it is a
process  that in reality there is no end they
will always be getting richer there
will never be enough time it is
us our strategies that
we do to be able to get the most out of it that the
business will always change it is healthy
that is that reality persists over time
we have to adapt to  make
solutions that adapt to those changes,
not only the reverse,
but also propose
corrective changes in terms of how they
have how we are going to go into production
with this, some quick considerations,
we always try to respect
the times, provide solutions in time and
that is why we use many
incremental deliverables in vip is not trying to
develop six months to a
large project but what  and in periods of two
files the afternoon show value onemi
peace work that after thinking backwards
I don't want to use spark so let's move
everything to be able to sparks and not the
other way around
understand the problem and what is the best
technology for that fitur profit profit
in  the sense of getting ahead a little, that
is, we are going to develop something that works
for this campaign, but we know that in
three campaigns this is going to happen, getting
ahead of the technology a bit, we
are going to be using it for it and not getting
complicated, not starting with the regional one, it
is like that because yes  but to analyze the
ensemble problem well, we give the results,
they know
that, so to start at least is and
then to make it more complex, not to do
knife in the sense of starting with
logistical reviews and then we are
testing, we know what is working well and what
is not,
and about two  last repetitions to
close on the one hand the subject of the data as
long as we take care of them because the
systems have been changing they will always
approve 20,000  technologies over
time, the important thing is how the data is
taken care of over time to be able to do something
with it and lastly if they cannot
solve a problem it is perhaps because
they are really playing they are following
the rules, that is,
if they follow as you see the rules that it
imposes  the business just like that to continue
has these problems then it is to
break this dilemma it is precisely
about how we respond to this
context and we propose a change
that is precisely what is now the
dilemma
so questions
listen to
questions
everyone is hungry and of course I am
too
hello  you said that when they analyzed the
client's data they initially generated, in
addition to the initial capes, some so that
the client understood the
quality of their data,
how do you make that transmission to the client
where your data is not useful, these data
are many, as you actually tell them by
the way  by light to use client and
prepare a coffee and for that it is a simple
report and if they have there  as an
evolution
of what happened with that report, they were given
the result of that return to the
customer over time, ok
if first they are super honest, I think
that the first day they tell you, you know what, I
have a disaster, that is, you can't  be
for him there is but I invite you to
tell me we know that this table is
wrong and this is good to be honest
entries precisely for working on
the problem and in terms of reports,
however we try to contrast in the
time of the reports that we are
doing how  it changes as
things improve even in the face of the
actions that are being taken they give us a
lot of feedback ok if we take this and
a campaign for example to complete
data then that the gender went from
I don't know
200 people who had an invalid gender
to 80 and that  It was already a change, so there it
is more or less to try to
identify the problems and try to
figure out how they are taking
actions regarding it.
or polar yes we are polar
but they themselves invite you to we know
that things are more and let's work on
it
hello thanks for sharing all this in
this question there is a plan to open
güssing if I was going to say
the idea is precisely we are
developing the lack of this  to
finish some files that will
stabilize some pitchers and
play a role in continuous integration to be able to
keep it up for time and when
it is ready for
collaborators to enter precisely the constant idea
next year after opening is
quite developed for that we wait for
the year that in  do it open source and that
prepares you enough to be able to receive
collaborations
we already have thanks for reminding me
if you want to know if you can tell us a
little about how the team is structured
regarding the roles and these tasks
that we have for business analysis
yes for that is  to start a skin without
minimally we have to release two
data agents, one leader and the other  or in
charge and a dating in jr and a personal
executor for that follow-up that is
the minimum we need to be able to
talk about a plus and then when
everything goes well and we start to
use development payton roles begin to enter
little more
engineering effort to automate
things in publix and even as you saw the one with
the afro that is quite good there
are also developers who integrate that
data receive the information and try to
show it as well as possible it connects a
lot in that sense so there  they are
the most full stack developers which is
fine they are on another team they interact a
lot for the executor that
the data is displayed which is more or less in
terms of
always we have a good proportion of
the distinguished agents equipped to
move fast
here we have one last good good
the situation is very good thanks
to the survey that said a high
rate of failure in fat
saints project as it goes and  cold and what elections
could we have no fault we
have to say no really not going to say
now seriously no there was not
always we kept improving the
current approach that is to say
we always beat it if you want a
competition scheme to the current time we always
we won in the capi and
that change was significant when they told me to avoid team
try to come the significance of the
improvement of the flip and it always stayed that
way obviously it is challenging to see that
the campaign starts and they are good and
equal sometimes it is also
luckily  the numbers have been going well
in terms of the approaches that we made
campaign and texting and this of the
projects that fail in reality I think
that they happen more on the client side
where they say that we want to make data
to develop a team and they do not know
how to put it together and  misses that impact
always hits that scenario
and